calleb a coder at the world's largest
Internet company wins a competition to
spend a week at the mountain retreat of
his reclusive billionaire boss Nathan he
cannot believe his look and he's even
more surprised to find out he's there to
interact with a female robot called Ava
created by Nathan and to find out
whether she's truly self-aware like a
human being as I walked into the cinema
to watch ex machina my expectations were
sky-high first of all because of the
trio of uber talented actors who star in
the film
that's Alyssa vikander Oscar Isaac and
domhnall gleeson and second because
writer Alex Garland has pretty much
nailed every script he's written from 28
days later to Dredd speaking of which I
would love to see a Dredd sequel so
sadly it looks like that ain't gonna
happen anyway
how could ex machina possibly live up to
my level of anticipation well not only
did it live up to it but it actually
exceeded it as well as writing ex
machina Alex Carla makes his debut in
the director's chair and he excels in
both departments the script is clever
and coherent while the visuals are
simply stunning because so much of ex
machina is about calleb Nathan and Ava
getting to know each other most of the
film revolves around conversations
between them rather than action in the
hands of Garland's this isn't a problem
though as he's written a dialogue driven
script that's full of tension deals with
big issues in a clear manner and is
consistently fascinating in fact I was
gripped from the start right through to
the end by Garland's perfect blend of
intelligent sci-fi and psychological
thriller infused with horror and he's
also managed to inject a good dose of
humor into the film too sometimes in the
most unlikely moments and this works
just wonderfully look at in particular
for one of the best dance scenes I've
seen in a very long time he's also sewn
with a crack team of on-screen and
behind-the-scenes talent who really make
the film pop if you've watched my review
of the wartime drama testament of youth
you'll know how highly I think of
Swedish actress Alyssa vikander and you
can click here to watch that video and
she's just as dazzling again in ex
machina giving another finely honed
performance as female robot Ava vikander
speech facial expressions gestures in
gate all combined
beautifully to suggest an other nurse
intermingled with humanity and you can
sense vikander's early training as a
ballerina in the way she's able to
completely control her body brilliantly
blurring the line between how humans and
robots move Oscar Isaac brings Nathan to
life
oh so superbly which is hardly
surprising given his past performances
in films like drive inside Llewyn Davis
and a most violent year he's one of
those actors who can totally vanish into
a roll and he does so to great effect in
ex machina Isaac cleverly balances his
performance on a knife edge between what
Nathan is like on the surface and what
he's like underneath so despite Nathan's
super-chill demeanor and his apparent
air of down-to-earth mate eNOS there's
more than a trace of the supreme control
freak about him between his superb turn
in ex machina
and roles coming up in star wars and
x-men apocalypse the next 18 months are
going to be huge for Isaac just like
Isaac and vikander domhnall gleeson star
is very much on the rise this year with
episode 7 among a number of films to see
him in in 2015
Gleason's worked before with both
vikander and Alex garland on Joe
Wright's adaptation of Anna Karenina and
on the sci-fi action movie Dredd and he
impresses yet again in ex machina with
an intelligent and natural performance
as the softly spoken Caleb oh and if you
want to find out more about what the
year ahead holds for Oscar Isaac
domhnall gleeson and Alyssa vikander
click here to watch my video on the top
10 actors you must watch in 2015 much
deserved props also go to
cinematographer Rob Hardy and this is
actually his first sci-fi movie he's
worked on he did an exceptional job on
testament of youth and his work on ex
machina is outstanding comic book asked
its jock who did the early concept
design for Ava and the movies visual
effects team have also done an AB C's
stellar job bringing Ava to life and I
must also mention production designer
Marc Digby and set decorator
Michelle day whose work is so crucial to
the whole eerily beautiful feel of the
film outside Nathan's home can research
facility there are acres of gorgeous
wilderness full with mountains trees and
waterfalls but the building's
geographical isolation coupled with the
fact that callebs more or less confined
there gives the whole film a decidedly
austra phobic atmosphere after that the
building sleek lines and toned down
modernist feel and the whole space feels
strangely unsettling to sum up ex
machina is a superlative sci-fi flick
that benefits from an outstanding script
pitch perfect performances and stunning
visuals what's not to like ex machina
gets 5 out of 5 flicks so what did you
think of ex machina and what's your
favorite robot movie + how would you
react to a world of sentient robots let
me know in the comments below and if you
liked this video hit the thumbs-up
button and subscribe for my weekly movie
reviews and interviews
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
you